instead of controlling parts of multiple
universes well we can now control
everything yeah we can instantly create
or destroy any Universe of our choosing
not only that but time would become a
new toy for us to play with we can now
manipulate it any way we want feel free
to create multiple timelines maybe I'll
create one where I'm the president or I
have blonde hair or maybe one where I'm
super jacked
and with all these multiverses Humanity
wouldn't be the only
Civilization by now there's a good
chance that we've discovered or even
created multiple civilizations of other
new species across different universes
ones that range from type zero to type
5 and of course with us at the top of
the food chain Humanity would be the
rulers of these civilizations